que podría acabar con la existencia del Reino Unido.
Así que fue un inmenso golpe para mí,
y también fue un inmenso golpe para muchas personas,
pero también fue algo que, en los siguientes días,
creó una crisis política
en mi país.
Hubo llamados para un segundo referéndum,
casi como si, imitando los deportes,
pudiéramos pedir a la oposición la repetición de un juego.
Todos culpaban a los demás.
La gente culpó al primer ministro
en primer lugar por convocar el referéndum.
Culparon al líder de la oposición por no luchar lo suficiente.
Los jóvenes acusaron a los viejos.
Gente con formación culpó a la gente con menos formación.
Toda esta crisis empeoró
por el elemento más trágico:
los niveles de xenofobia y actos de racismo en las calles de Gran Bretaña
a un nivel nunca antes visto
en mi vida.
Todos comentan que ahora sí mi país está convirtiéndose en una pequeña Inglaterra,
o, como uno de mis colegas comentó,
si estábamos a punto de convertirnos en un parque temático de nostalgia de los 50
a la deriva en el Océano Atlántico.
(Risas)
Pero mi pregunta es,
¿deberíamos tener el grado de shock que hemos experimentado desde entonces?
¿Fue algo que sucedió de la noche a la mañana?
¿O hay factores más profundos que nos han llevado a donde estamos hoy?
Quiero dar un paso atrás y plantear dos simples preguntas.
Primero, ¿qué representa el Brexit,
no solo para mi país,
sino también para el mundo?
Y segundo, ¿qué podemos hacer al respecto?
¿Cómo deberíamos responder?
Primero, ¿qué representa el Brexit?
En retrospectiva es algo maravilloso.
El Brexit nos enseña muchas cosas sobre nuestra sociedad
y sobre las sociedades en el mundo.
Resalta de varias maneras que parecemos no ser conscientes
de lo muy dividida que están nuestras sociedades.
La votación se repartió por edad, formación, clase y geografía.
Los jóvenes no participaron en gran número de la votación,
solo aquellos que querían permanecer.
Las personas de más edad querían realmente salir de la Unión Europea.
Geográficamente, fueron Londres y Escocia los más comprometidos
con ser parte de la Unión Europea,
mientras que en otras partes del país hubo una fuerte ambivalencia.
Esas divisiones son algo que realmente necesitamos reconocer y tomar seriamente.
Pero en mayor profundidad, la votación nos enseña algo
sobre la naturaleza de las política hoy en día.
La política contemporánea no es solo derecha e izquierda.
no se trata solo de impuestos y gastos.
Se trata de globalización.
El error de la política contemporánea oscila entre quienes abrazan la globalización
y aquellos que temen la globalización.
(Aplausos)
Sí observamos el porqué de aquellos que quisieron salir,
los llamamos "salientes", como oposición a los "quedantes",
vemos dos factores en las encuestas de opinión
que realmente importan.
El primero fue la inmigración, y segundo la soberanía,
y estos representan un deseo para la gente de retomar el control de sus vidas
y el sentimiento de no contar con representación de los políticos.
Pero estas ideas son las que significan miedo y alienación.
Representan una retirada hacia el nacionalismo y las fronteras
que muchos de nosotros rechazaríamos.
Lo que quiero sugerir es que el panorama es más complicado que eso,
internacionalistas liberales,
como yo, y me incluyo firmemente en ese panorama,
necesitamos ponernos de nuevo dentro del panorama
con el fin de entender cómo hemos llegado a donde estamos hoy.
Cuando observamos los patrones de votación dentro del Reino Unido,
podemos ver las divisiones visiblemente.
Las áreas azules muestran los "quedantes"
y las rojas los "salientes".
Cuando miramos esto,
lo que me toca personalmente es el poco tiempo en mi vida
que he pasado en muchas áreas rojas.
De repente me doy cuenta de que, mirando al top de 50 áreas en Reino Unido
que votaron por salir,
he pasado un total de 4 días de mi vida en esas áreas.
En algunos de esos lugares,
ni siquiera conozco los nombres de los distritos electorales.
Fue un gran golpe para mí,
y esto sugirió que personas como yo
que se piensan a sí mismas como inclusivas, abiertas y tolerantes,
quizás no conocen sus propios países y sociedades
tan bien como queremos creer.
(Aplausos)
Y el reto que viene es que debemos encontrar una nueva manera
de narrar la globalización a esa gente,
para reconocer que a esas personas que no fueron a la universidad,
que no crecieron con Internet,
que no tienen la oportunidad de viajar,
quizás no les seduce la narrativa que encontramos persuasiva
en nuestras burbujas a menudo liberales.
(Aplausos)
Esto significa que necesitamos ir más a fondo y entender.
En el voto para salir, una minoría declaró políticas de miedo y odio,
creando mentiras y desconfianza
alrededor, por ejemplo, de la idea de que el voto pro-Europa
podría reducir el número de refugiados y solicitantes de asilo hacia Europa,
cuando el voto para salir no tenía nada que ver con inmigración
desde fuera de la Unión Europea.
Pero para una mayoría significativa de los votantes por la salida
la preocupación era una desilusión con la clase política.
Esto era un voto de protesta para muchos,
un sentido de que nadie los representaba,
que no podían encontrar un partido político que hablara por ellos,
y así rechazaron esa clase política.
Esto se replica alrededor de Europa y en muchas democracias liberales en el mundo.
Lo vemos con el aumento de popularidad de Donald Trump en EE. UU.,
con el creciente nacionalismo de Viktor Orbán en Hungría,
con el incremento de popularidad de Marine Le Pen en Francia.
El espectro del Brexit está en todas nuestras sociedades.
Por eso creo que debemos plantearnos mi segunda pregunta
de cómo deberíamos responder colectivamente.
Para todos los que nos preocupamos por crear
sociedades liberales, abiertas y tolerantes.
Necesitamos urgentemente una nueva visión,
la visión de una globalización más tolerante e inclusiva,
una que acerque las personas a nosotros en lugar de dejarlas rezagadas.
Esa visión de globalización
tiene que empezar por un reconocimiento
de los beneficios positivos de la globalización.
Hay consenso entre los economistas
en que un libre comercio, el movimiento de capital,
el movimiento de personas a través de las fronteras
beneficia a todos globalmente.
Hay consenso entre los académicos en relaciones internacionales,
en que la globalización trae independencia,
lo cual trae cooperación y paz.
Pero la globalización también tiene efectos redistributivos.
Crea ganadores y perdedores.
Para tomar un ejemplo de migración,
sabemos que la inmigración es una red positiva para toda la economía
en cualquier circunstancia.
Pero también tenemos que ser muy precavidos
en que hay consecuencias redistributivas,
y es importante, la inmigración poco cualificada
puede llevar a una reducción de salarios para los más pobres de nuestras sociedades
y así ejercer presión en los precios de la vivienda.
Esto no quita que sea positivo,
pero significa que más personas deben compartir esos beneficios
y reconocerlos.
En 2002 el exsecretario general de Naciones Unidas, Kofi Annan,
dio un discurso en la Universidad de Yale
y ese discurso trató el tema de la globalización inclusiva.
Fue el discurso donde se acuñó ese término.
Y dijo, y lo cito,
"La casa de cristal de la globalización tiene que estar abierta a todos
si esto resulta más seguro.
La intolerancia y la ignorancia
son la cara fea de una globalización excluyente y antagonista".
La idea de globalización inclusiva fue apenas retomada en el 2008
en una conferencia sobre gobernanza progresiva
en la que participaron muchos líderes de los países europeos.
Pero en medio de la austeridad y la crisis financiera del 2008,
el concepto desapareció casi sin dejar rastro.
Han tomado la globalización para apoyar la agenda neoliberal.
Es percibida como parte de una agenda de élite
en lugar de algo que beneficie a todos.
Y debemos volver a reclamarla sobre una base mucho más inclusiva
de lo que es hoy.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿cómo podemos cumplir esa meta?
¿Cómo mantener el equilibrio por un lado, abordando el miedo y la alienación
y por otro rechazando vehementemente
caer en la xenofobia y el nacionalismo?
Esa es la pregunta para todos nosotros.
Y creo que, como científico social,
que las ciencias sociales ofrecen algo para empezar.
Nuestra transformación tiene que ser de ideas y en el plano de material.
Quiero darles cuatro ideas como punto de partida.
La primera se refiere a la educación cívica.
Lo que se destaca del Brexit
es la brecha entre la percepción pública y la realidad empírica.
Se dice que nos hemos convertido en una sociedad postfáctica
donde la evidencia y la verdad ya no importan,
y que las mentiras tienen el mismo estatus que la evidencia de las pruebas.
Entonces, ¿cómo podemos...
(Aplausos)
cómo reconstruir respeto a la verdad y la evidencia
en nuestras democracias liberales?
Hay que empezar con educación
pero hay que comenzar reconociendo la existencia de enormes brechas.
En 2014, la encuestadora Ipsos MORI
publicó una encuesta sobre las actitudes hacia la inmigración,
y mostró que a medida que aumentaba el número de inmigrantes,
la preocupación pública por la inmigración aumentaba;
A pesar de que, obviamente, esto no revela la causalidad,
porque esto podría pasar igualmente con números más reducidos,
pero esto lo genera la narrativa política y de los medios en torno a este tema.
Pero el mismo estudio reveló
una enorme falta de información pública
e incomprensión acerca de la naturaleza de la inmigración.
Por ejemplo, en estas actitudes en el Reino Unido,
el público creía que los niveles de asilo
componen una mayor proporción de la inmigración de lo que en realidad son,
pero también creía que los niveles educativos de la migración
eran mucho más bajos que la migración total,
de lo que en realidad son.
Así que hay que afrontar esta falta de información,
la brecha entre percepción y realidad en aspectos clave de la globalización.
Y eso no puede hacerse solo en nuestras escuelas,
aunque es importante comenzar a una edad temprana.
Debe haber participación cívica toda la vida
y el compromiso público de que todos somos parte de la sociedad.
Lo segundo que creo que es una oportunidad
es la idea de fomentar mayor interacción a través de diversas comunidades.
(Aplausos)
Una de las cosas destacables y muy llamativas para mí,
al observar las actitudes ante la inmigración en el Reino Unido,
es que, irónicamente, las regiones de mi país
que son más tolerantes con los inmigrantes
tienen el mayor número de inmigrantes.
Así, por ejemplo, Londres y el sureste tienen el mayor número de inmigrantes,
y también son, con mucho, las más tolerantes.
En aquellas áreas del país donde tienen los niveles más bajos de inmigración
en realidad, son los más excluyentes e intolerantes hacia los inmigrantes.
Así que tenemos que fomentar los programas de intercambio.
Hay que garantizar que generaciones de mayores que tal vez no pueden viajar
logren el acceso a Internet.
Hay que alentar, incluso a nivel local y nacional,
más movimiento, más participación,
una mayor interacción con personas que no conocemos
con cuyos puntos de vista uno no necesariamente puede estar de acuerdo.
Sin embargo, lo tercero que creo que es crucial,
y esto es realmente fundamental,
es que tenemos que garantizar que todo el mundo comparte
los beneficios de la globalización.
Esta ilustración del Financial Times post-Brexit es realmente sorprendente.
Muestra trágicamente que aquellas personas que votaron por salir de la Unión Europea
eran en realidad los más beneficiados materialmente
del comercio con la Unión Europea.
Pero el problema es que esa gente en esas áreas
no se autopercibían como beneficiarios.
No creían que, en realidad, recibían los beneficios materiales
por el mayor comercio y por una mayor movilidad en todo el mundo.
Trabajo en cuestiones predominantemente relacionadas con refugiados,
y una de las ideas que prediqué durante mucho tiempo,
principalmente en los países en desarrollo de todo el mundo,
es que para fomentar la integración de los refugiados,
no podemos beneficiar a las poblaciones de refugiados,
hay que abordar las preocupaciones de las comunidades de acogida en áreas locales.
Pero al observar esto,
una de las recetas políticas es que se deben ofrecer
desproporcionadamente mejores instalaciones educativas,
centros de salud, acceso a los servicios sociales
en aquellas regiones con alta inmigración
para abordar las preocupaciones de las poblaciones locales.
Pero mientras que lo fomentamos en el mundo en desarrollo,
no aplicamos esas lecciones en casa
ni las incorporamos en nuestras propias sociedades.
Por otra parte, si tomamos muy en serio la necesidad
de asegurar de que las personas participan de los beneficios económicos,
nuestras empresas y corporaciones necesitan un modelo de globalización
que reconozca que ellos también tienen que acoger a la gente en ellos.
La cuarta y última idea que quiero proponer
es la idea de que necesitamos políticas más responsables.
Hay muy poca evidencia en las ciencias sociales
que compara actitudes sobre la globalización.
Pero a partir de los estudios existentes,
podemos ver que hay gran variación entre los diferentes países
y períodos de tiempo en los países
sobre las actitudes y la tolerancia
acerca de temas como migración y movilidad por una parte
y el libre comercio por la otra.
Pero una hipótesis que emerge tras una mirada superficial a los datos
es que las sociedades polarizadas son mucho menos tolerantes con la globalización.
Son las sociedades como Suecia en el pasado,
como Canadá hoy en día,
donde hay una política de centro,
donde derecha e izquierda trabajan juntas,
lo que favorece actitudes de apoyo hacia la globalización.
Y lo que vemos en todo el mundo hoy es una polarización trágica,
un fracaso en el diálogo entre los extremos en la política,
y una brecha en términos de la base centro liberal
que puede fomentar la comunicación y un entendimiento compartido.
Puede que no se logre en la actualidad,
pero por lo menos hay que pedir a políticos y medios de comunicación
dejar el lenguaje del miedo y que sean mucho más tolerantes unos con otros.
(Aplausos)
Estas ideas son muy provisionales,
y es así en parte porque esto debe ser un proyecto incluyente y compartido
Todavía soy británico.
Todavía soy europeo.
Todavía soy un ciudadano del mundo.
Para aquellos que creemos
que nuestras identidades no son mutuamente excluyentes,
tenemos que trabajar todos juntos
para asegurar que la globalización nos incluye a todos
y no deja a nadie atrás.
Solo entonces podremos conciliar la democracia y la globalización.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)